Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de en 5
minutos
Qatar un país pequeño con un clima
hostil y sin la infraestructura
necesaria fue elegido en 2010 como sede
de la copa del mundo 2022 en este
episodio en 5 minutos les contamos
Cuáles son las principales controversias
que rodean al evento derechos laborales
las denuncias de explotación laboral es
llevaron a amnistía internacional a
describir la cita como la Copa Mundial
de la vergüenza según el diario
británico de Guardian al menos 6.500
trabajadores migrantes murieron en el
país desde 2010 el país se volcó a la
titánica tarea de construir siete
estadios más de 100 hoteles redes viales
y hasta una ciudad luz ahí que albergará
la final esto requirió la llegada de
mares de trabajadores de otros países
que buscaban empleo para hacernos una
idea en 2010 el país tenía una población
de 1,63 millones de personas para 2017
esta ya aumentado a 2,67 millones con un
gran porcentaje de población migrante
los abusos laborales No son nuevos en
Qatar robo o atraso de salarios trabajo
forzoso o falta de protección jurídica
son algunos de ellos el gobierno asegura
que está en progreso de mejorar su
sistema laboral pero rechaza las
acusaciones de explotación a migrantes
derechos humanos múltiples
organizaciones de derechos denuncian el
autoritarismo del gobierno catarí por su
falta de respeto a las libertades
ciudadanas pocos días antes del pitazo
inicial el reportero danés ras Mustang
fue amenazado mientras transmitía en
directo Aunque ofrecieron disculpas el
hecho generó zozobra entre la prensa
extranjera Y por supuesto uno de los
principales temores Es la falta de
garantías para las mujeres
leyes profundamente discriminatorias les
niegan la posibilidad de tomar
decisiones sobre sus propias vidas y las
ponen bajo el tutelaje de una figura
masculina las mujeres de tener
relaciones extramatrimoniales pueden ser
incluso lapidadas y en caso de violación
también suelen ser condenadas la
población
lgbtiq más también está en riesgo el
código penal dice que determinados actos
entre personas del mismo sexo pueden ser
castigados con penas de prisión
humansía internacional han denunciado
detenciones arbitrarias maltrato o
incluso flagelaciones y por si fuera
poco un embajador del país de la Copa
Mundial llegó a describir la
homosexualidad como un daño mental leyes
y costumbres como estado árabe
ultraconservador donde la religión es la
ley
Qatar plantea más retos en el país el
consumo de alcohol está totalmente
prohibido Aunque durante el Mundial las
autoridades permitieron el consumo a Los
visitantes solamente en algunos espacios
y horarios determinados lo que afecta
directamente a grandes patrocinadores de
la Copa como Budweiser está mal visto
tomar de la a tu pareja o cualquier otra
muestra pública de afecto aunque las
parejas no casadas podrán compartir
habitación en los hoteles las relaciones
fuera del matrimonio están prohibidos
por otro lado el país insta a Los
visitantes a acomodarse a las normas que
prohíben llevar lo que llaman ropa
reveladora en público acusaciones de
corrupción catar tuvo 22 si es y 14 no
es para albergar el mundial en aquel
entonces en 2010 no era ni de cerca el
favorito tras ello yo vieron acusaciones
de corrupción de que el comité ejecutivo
de la FIFA había sido sobornado la
prensa británica destapó una trama en la
que se vieron involucrados el entonces
presidente de la UEFA del francés
Michelle platini el Cameron es Isa
hayatú y el marfilenio jacks anuma ambos
integrantes del comité ejecutivo de la
FIFA el presidente de la federación
catari y titular de la federación
asiática de fútbol Mohamed binham habría
pagado hasta 3,6 millones dólares a 30
miembros de la FIFA para asegurar el
voto el propio Joseph blatter que era
presidente de la FIFA al momento de la
asignación de la sede dijo incluso que
había sido un error elegir acatar como
sede del mundial el departamento de
justicia de Estados Unidos inició una
investigación y acusó directamente a
acatar de haber pagado sobornos algo que
los organizadores niegan calendario es
el primer mundial que se celebra en
noviembre y diciembre fechas polémicas
Pues en muchos casos dejan a las
elecciones sin tiempo suficiente para el
trabajo conjunto y con impacto en los
jugadores que en plena temporada llegan
lesionados o simplemente no llegan
impacto climático la incidencia del
evento en el cambio climático también es
cuestionado si bien catarse comprometió
a ofrecer una copa mundial totalmente
neutra en carbono y el país alberga la
copa en sus meses menos calurosos
organiza ambientalistas la acusan de
gringoshing la FIFA asegurado que la
construcción de los estadios ha seguido
los lineamientos sostenibles y que no
son necesarios vuelos en avión entre los
distintos puntos de competición pero
organizaciones como periodistas por el
planeta aseguran que la construcción de
los estadios requirió mucha energía
proveniente del petróleo y critican que
se haya instalado aire acondicionado en
todos los estadios ya que consumirá
mucha más energía este largo inventario
de perros hace de este mundial uno de
los más polémicos de la historia y
preocupa a los defensores de los
Derechos Humanos que los eventos
deportivos de alta índole sean cada vez
más utilizados como lavados de cara por
los países adinerados y les sirvió el
vídeo para entender a las controversias
que rodean al Mundial de Qatar los
esperamos en otro episodio en 5 minutos
en France 24 y France 24.com